Hello and welcome to fire of learning.
There are many more ethnicities
and cultures in this
world and there are nation
states.
Sometimes nations are the products of
multiple groups coming together and
coexisting. Other Times people don't
fit together so easily in feel.
The creation and protection of their
own nation is imperative to the group
survival.
Other times different groups of the same
people split over ideological or social
disagreements.
In this video,
we're going to be doing a brief overview
of 25 independence movements on a
continent of Europe alone.
25 countries.
That's a huge number y. Well,
looking at the map of Europe,
things have not always looked like this.
The Nation States of Europe, as I said,
often contain many different peoples.
In the UK for example,
there are five independence Momenta
we'll be discussing in Spain.
There are four main ones
and six historic ones. Now,
some separatist movements
are only supported by a small
amount of the population,
but some have such popular support that
they may soon be coming to a map near
you.
Please keep in mind though,
I will share the opinions
of people regarding the
independence of their regions.
These opinions are not necessarily my own
and my personal opinions will as usual
be left out of the video. So first
off, let's look at the United Kingdom.
Number one Scotland. Scotland is
perhaps the most notable on us,
less because it's the only one among them
that had an indisputable legal vote on
independence. Within recent
times. On September 18th,
2014 Scotland voted on the question of
its independence from the United Kingdom
with the voter turnout of
84.5% of the population.
55.3% voted no and 44.7% voted yes despite
the poor results for those in support
of independence, the question still may
not be settled because for many Scotts,
the issues have not been resolved.
The division between England and
Scotland goes back for centuries.
England and Scotland fought for many
years over the Middle Ages until 1603 when
they shared the same monarch and in
1707 legally became a United Kingdom.
Scotland's autonomy has
increased over the past century,
but still many Scots are in favor of
independence for cultural reasons such as
the protection of their language
and identity, but economic,
political and social reasons as well,
such as managing Scotland's
natural resources,
having an independent Scottish voice on
the global political stage and making
other decisions which Scotland
may support, but England does not.
Number two whales, another Celtic
nation who's disputes with England,
go back to the foundations
of the two nations.
They'll relations between England and
Wales gradually became much smoother than
those between England and Scotland.
Talk of independence came back
in the 19th and 20th centuries.
The Welsh independence
movement is for the more,
not as vocal as Collins when Scotland
McGann calling for independence.
Many Welsh felt that a debate must be held
concerning Welsh independence as well,
but they are certainly
not at the same point.
Surveys across the country very claiming
anywhere from three to 20% of the
population is in favor of Welsh.
Independence support is strongest in
northern Wales where over half the
population may be in favor of it.
Number three Northern Ireland,
most northern Irish favor remaining
within the United Kingdom,
others with joining the rest of Ireland.
However,
some perhaps up to 15% of the population
are in favor of the creation of an
independent Northern Ireland
or Republic of Ulster.
The reason for this is that many Northern
Irish to not feel truly Irish nor
truly British Northern Ireland's origins
lie in the 17th century when the area
was colonized by Protestant English and
Scottish settlers to reduce resistance
to English rural.
Today,
Irish Protestants are still slightly
the majority of the country.
The solution to this identity crisis
as well as a number of political and
economic issues and disputes and their
eyes could be an independent ulcer.
Number four, Cornwall,
though sometimes forgotten,
the Cornish identity is and has been
distinct from English identity since the
founding of the nation as well.
Cornish and English were regarded as
separate for well over a thousand years.
However,
in recent centuries,
the decline of the Cornish language has
slightly significantly contributed to
the loss of identity.
The Cornish,
much like the Welsh are descended from
the Celtic inhabitants of the island
before Anglo Saxon rule.
They speak a Celtic language,
have Celtic heritage and in their view
have a separate perspective on the world
and their English counterparts.
Accordingly,
over half the population supports
greater autonomy for the region and some
support independence altogether.
Some radicals such as the members of a
Cornish nationalist group known as on
golf may have even been connected to
pro Cornish violence in recent decades.
Number five,
the Isle of Man,
the fifth and final independence movement
in the United Kingdom is that of the
Isle of Man, another Celtic
nation predating the Anglo Saxons.
The Manx have existed as a unique
identity for millennia despite having been
ruled by Vikings Scotts
and of course now the UK,
a separatist movement known as [inaudible]
or the makes National Party has been
active since the 1960s along with the
goals of protecting them makes language,
culture and identity.
They also believe that
English administration is
negatively affecting the island
and the party's goals are to restore the
island's environment, halt immigration,
build the university,
and make the island more self sufficient.
Now to look at France number six Brittany.
Brittany is considered the six Celtic
nation after the five which we have just
discussed,
but it is located in northwest
France rather than the British isles.
Brittany has a Celtic heritage language
and culture is similar to that of Wales
and Cornwall and in fact shares a history.
Brittany as a nation existed until 1547
when it was annexed by the Kingdom of
France. Since then, it is
assimilated into French culture,
but within the past century of Britain,
identity has resurfaced and many
Britons are calling for more recognized
identity, greater autonomy, or
even independence from France.
Around 18% of the population
supports in the pennants,
while 37% consider themselves
Breton's first and French.
Second number seven,
Corsica.
Corsica is a Mediterranean island which
has historically switched hands between
multiple nations, even for a time
existing as an independent nation,
but eventually it came into
the hands of the French.
In the 18th century there was resistance
to invasion but eventually acquired
many Corsicans have always felt
closer to Italians and French,
but ultimately and independent people
along with threats to the language and
culture.
Corsicans have also felt that
their economy has declined
and that they had been
subject to large amounts of immigration
from peoples from the former French
empire, which they don't consent
to in the later 20th century.
Economic pressures led to the founding
of militant groups in Corsica and in the
Alaria incident in
August of 1975 of course,
it can rebels clash with French forces.
In recent polls,
around 15% of the population
supports complete independence.
30% view is independence as a positive
notion and over 50% would prefer more
autonomy from France.
Number eight, all sauce.
Another example of a nation in between
nations that is in ways related to both
but not quite either.
All sauce rest in between
France and Germany and the
region has been fought over
for centuries,
eventually becoming permanently French
after world war two with their own
language, identity and culture. Many
Alsatians push for greater autonomy.
Some for unity with Germany,
but some for independence altogether for
the more all sauce is one of the most
religious and conservative regions in
France and strain with the government
often further encourages
their separate identity.
Number nine Occitania Occitania
covers most of southern France,
but extends into Spain and Italy as well.
Oxygen nationalism is rooted in the fact
that accidents have a unique identity,
culture and language as opposed to
French dating back as early as the middle
ages until the regions were subdued
by conquest and interest in oxygen.
Nationalism was brought up in the 1960s
as the French government's economic
reforms took a focus on the north of the
country via autonomy and independence
movements. Last speed during the
1980s button. Recent years even,
there have been a number of protests
and movements focusing on an oxygen and
identity and voice, and now for
Belgium. Number 10 Wallonia.
Ever since Belgium's independence
in the early 19th century,
the people of will loon have asserted
their own identity in the nation.
This identity which emphasizes French
culture and language has led to some alone
Ian's to refer a policy of Ritaj
Shazam to rejoin with France.
Others, however, see what Clonea as
an independent nation. Historically,
the Bologna and movement was closely
linked with socialists activity in Belgium
seeing the nation of Belgium
as a capitalist creation
in recent times harbor,
the dispute has focused more on culture
and identity and a solution to the
complicated politics of dodgem.
Number 11 Flenders with the
independence of balloon.
There is also a more culturally and
linguistically Dutch group known as the
Flemish in the north of Belgium.
Belgium was historically
led by francophones and
French language and culture
were favored in the nation.
In fact,
Dutch speakers who were skeptical of
independence from the Netherlands and
Flanders sometimes have their houses rated
the solution for some today and we'll
loon and Flinders remains the disillusion
of Belgium between the groups were
more French and were Dutch.
However,
around three quarters of Flanders is
opposed to this solution and now for the
many independence movements of Spain.
Number 12 Catalonia.
Spain was historically the combination
of multiple different peoples and many of
these people's never
quite lost their identity.
Catalonia is perhaps the best example
of this as it is one of the most active
independence movements in
Europe and in fact the world.
In 2017 though there was a low voter
turnout of only 43% of the population.
91% of them voted for
Catalan independence.
Separatist groups have argued that
police oppression of voters led to a low
voter turnout and perhaps as much
as 55% of the region we have voted.
However,
anti independence groups believe the
voting process was flawed and that issues
such as the same people
voting twice were present.
Polls show a mix of results and
though 91% of voters voted for Catalan
independence, it's likely that most of
the population is against it. However,
it is very close,
bordering around 50% subsequently,
Catalonia is parliament held a vote for
independence approving the measure on
October 27th,
2017 however,
the Spanish government deemed it
illegal and try to prevent anything from
happening from the start and
the international community
does not recognize it.
There are many reasons for us, such a
strong push for Catalan independence.
There are of course, cultural
linguistic and social forces at work.
Catalans have their own language and
identity and history which they feel has
been suppressed by the Spanish government.
There are as well major economic forces.
Catalonia constitutes only about one
20th of Spain land but holds one fifth of
its economic input.
Furthermore,
20% of Spain's tax revenue comes from
Catalonia leading to a situation where
Catalonia supports the poor regions of
Spain and sees less of its tax revenue
returning to its own region.
Obviously Spain is not eager to let its
most profitable region go and most of
Europe sides with a Spanish on the issue.
For the moment the decision remains in
question as Catalonians themselves are
about equally divided on what is truly
best for the country. And people.
Number 13 the Basque republic.
There is a similar situation for
the people of the Basque country,
which is in northern Spain
but also extends into France.
The Basque people have their own
culture identity language. In fact,
their language is one of the
most unique in the world.
It's origins are rather mysterious really,
but it is also another economically
prosperous region and Spain and thus the
region economically supports
the poor regions of the
nation as well. As a result,
there is a large amount of non Basque
immigration into the region which they
view is threatening.
The Basques and the Spanish government
have been in conflict for much of the
past hundred years that a dictatorship
of Francisco Franco was especially hard
on them as it was for other
groups in Spain as well.
This led to the bass conflict in 1959
with which lasted all the way up to 2011
hundreds were killed, thousands
were wounded. The Spanish regard,
the primary group responsible,
the Eta as terrorist and a bass regard
of the Spanish government as oppressors.
And thus today,
perhaps around 50% of the
Basque population is in
favor of independence with a
Basque National Party being supported
by around 40% of the population.
Number 14 the Canary Islands
being conquered by the
Spanish and 1402 the islands
have always had a sense of difference.
And Bob, you guessed it, a unique culture,
history and identity.
The Movement for Canarian independence
became much more supported in a 20th
century and today,
43.5% of the population feels
more Canarian in Spanish.
While 49.9% of the population
feels equally Canarian and Spanish,
only about 5% of the population said
they felt more Spanish than Canarian.
Accordingly,
political chaos in the future for Spain
would likely lead to a strong Movement
for independence.
Number 15 Galicia north of
Portugal in Northwestern Spain.
On June 27th,
1931 the Republic of Galicia declared
itself independent from Spain and maintain
this independence and sell June 28th
where after 27 hours rejoined the nation.
Glistens have their own language and the
unique history dating back all the way
to the early Middle Ages as
the Kingdom of glycemia. Today,
there is a push for greater autonomy
and even independence in the region.
Exact figures are unknown,
but Galician nationalists candidates
received the round 16% of the vote in a
2009 elections in the region beyond
these main ones and Luzia Castiel Aragon,
Conta Bria Leone,
Valencia and Mercia have movements for
both greater autonomy and in the eyes of
some independence.
Many of these movements have origins
in their histories in the middle ages,
but became particularly inflamed during
the fascist rural of Francisco Franco
and socialists upheaval in
Spain. Accordingly, to this day,
many pushing for outright independence
of these regions are associated with
socialist movements.
Number 16 so Louisiana or region,
which has been historically fought over
Sally's yet today is divided between the
Czech Republic, Poland, and Germany.
However many Salesian see themselves as
an independent group and some as none of
the three at all.
Exact numbers are not known,
but the movement is not really popular
and local elections for candidates who
support even greater autonomy,
typically only amount to about
three to 10% of the popular vote.
The region is also tied
with a less popular Moravian
independence movement also
in the Czech Republic,
which would leave Bohemia as the
remaining check land leading to a complete
breakup of the nation.
Number 17 foreign home,
a small island in the Baltic Sea belonging
to Denmark that people have borne
home with a unique history,
culture,
and language similar to Danish began to
consider independence from Denmark in
the 20th century following
economic and demographic issues.
Foreign home self government party says
it takes inspiration from Scotland and
points to Malta in Singapore as models
for his own independent existence.
Number 18 the Faroe Islands.
The Faroe Islands originally settled
by Vikings in the Middle Ages are still
owned by Denmark as they have been for
most of the past millennia with their own
language, identity, culture and such.
They do not feel Danish. However,
but rather see themselves as a unique
Norse group and push to be a separatist
nation. The islands did declare themselves
independent following World War II,
but Denmark declared it illegal.
Nevertheless,
the island's inhabitants still believe
in the cause of independence and feud
with Denmark over the issue.
However,
economic concerns have worry the island's
inhabitants about what's self may do
to them.
Number 19 the Olin islands,
the island islands off the
coast of Finland, Ra, primarily
Swedish speaking group,
the political party.
The future of Olin has sought independence
from Finland since 2003 with around
8% of the population
supporting the measure.
Very few support reunification was Sweden
because of historical disagreements
leading some to prefer independence.
Number 20 Bavaria before
Germany was a United nation,
it consisted of many different German
kingdoms. Among these was Bavaria,
Bavaria.
Traditionally a Catholic nation had much
more in common with Austria than it did
with the Protestant who
were unifying Germany.
Attempts were made to become independent,
especially during and after
World War One and two,
but these were largely unsuccessful.
Support for independence
declined over the decades,
but with volatile European politics in
independent Bavaria may be a favorable
option for the inhabitants in the
future and now for Italy, Italy,
like Germany is a more recent creation
for most of the past thousand years in
nation we call Italy was made
up of several different nations,
kingdoms and city states. Some of them
have accepted in Italian identity,
but others hold on to their
unique identities of the past.
Number 21 the Republic of Venice Veneto
with a capitol city of Venice along with
Scotland,
Catalonia and Abass is one of the more
major independence movements of Europe.
Venice as a nation existed for around
the thousand years before the unification
with Italy and accordingly they
have their own culture, identity,
language and history.
Perhaps up to 55% of the
population supports independence
and over 60% supports
at least greater autonomy.
After a number of protests
and unofficial referendums,
there were demands that an official
referendum be held and that the EU support
it.
In October of 2017 Venetians
held a referendum on the
question of whether or not
Venice,
it should have more autonomy and with
half the country voting a little over 90%
voted yes.
There have even been attempts
or suggestions of violence
such as in 2015 when a
group of nations were caught trying
to turn a tractor into a tank,
along with the socio cultural divides
and Benito economic issues are also a key
factor.
Venice generates a large amount of income
from trade and tourism such things,
but that money is used to fund the
poorer parts of Italy and not Venice.
A similar situation as was discussed
in Catalonia and the Basque region.
Number 20 to Sardinia with Corsica to
the north having its own independence
moment. Sardinia in the south
also has one of its own,
perhaps an even more popular one because
of Sardinia is unique history, culture,
and many languages as well as the
concern of protecting island environment.
45% of Sardinians reportedly
favor independence from
Italy and 40% prefer more
island autonomy.
According to polls around the quarter
of the island already claims the have no
loyalty to Italy and an additional 37%
claims to be more Sardinian than Italian.
While this may seem like Sardinia
should be among the other more active
independence movements,
the independence groups are fragmented
and divided among the islands,
various groups and interests.
Number 23 Cecily,
Cecily having been conquered and
ruled by a variety of nations over the
centuries and existing for a time as an
independent nation may want to return to
that status while not receiving a large
amount of support in the election.
Some polls indicate that 44% of Sicilians
find the concept of more autonomy or
even independence favorable.
Though information is limited,
the movements are also fragmented
as independence is favored by balls,
right wing and left wing groups.
If theoretically these Italian
independence movements were successful,
it could cause further fragmentation
and trigger a fragmentation of Italy
altogether,
particularly in regions seeking greater
autonomy even if not much independence
as of today, such as
Lombardi. Liguria and Friuli.
Alternatively,
however,
these regions may not break
off individually but may
come together to form the
nation of academia.
The day would be an Italian
nation consisting of the
northern provinces such as
Lombardi,
Benito and Piedmont.
Northern Italy is economically more
prosperous in the south and northern
Italians feel as though the southern
regions drag the nation behind.
According to polls,
58% of Italians with support such a thing
and in some regions results are much
higher up to 80% the number
24 Transnistria Transnistria
is unique and that it
is one of a few on this list actually
currently functioning as an independent
nation.
Following the collapse of the USSR,
Transnistria engaged in
conflict with Moldova,
a cease fire was declared
a few months later,
but the situation remains unresolved with
Moldova is still claiming the land in
2006 97% of the voting population of the
small area of voted for independence,
but few countries actually recognize it.
In fact,
the only ones which do are other
countries with disputed independence.
Number 25 northern Cyprus.
The divide on this tiny island came in
1983 after a coup d'etat and tending to
join the country with
Greece in 1974 failed.
This prompted Turkey to invade
the island and to this day,
northern Cyprus is heavily dependent
on Turkey support economically,
militarily and politically.
The North is heavily ethnically Turkish,
culturally Turkish and speaks Turkish
as opposed to the south which is
ethnically, culturally and
linguistically. More Greek.
Turkey is the only nation to
recognize its independence. However,
the area does essentially function
independently. Now then to summarize,
there are many movements for greater
autonomy in Europe and obviously these are
some which have evolved into
moments for independence.
The 25 we've discussed are
the most notable among them.
Over 10% of the population favors
independence and these regions marked with
purple over 40% favors it in the
orange regions and the pink regions.
Independence has been declared in
some forums and in the red regions.
The area essentially functions
independently and the
regions containing a star
violence has occurred at some point in
the past over the issue. As you can see,
the UK, Spain, and Italy are not
only facing independence movements,
but in fact,
success of such independence movements
could lead to a fracturing of the nations
into many smaller ones. As European
politics change over the next decade,
some of these movements will,
whether others may intensify,
some maybe come fully independent nations.
Ultimately,
the decision of whether or not to become
independent and whether or not that
choice is the right or the wrong one.
Rest in the population of these regions.
For more videos like this and
videos on many other subjects,
be sure to go out fire of learning
and subscribe. Thank you for watching.